Atomic Oxygen sounds like an element that
was exposed to radiation in the 1930s and
became a comic book superhero... but that’s
MY idea, OK?
I could make millions...
Hey Atomic Avengers, Ian here for DNews.
So scientists recently spotted atomic oxygen
on Mars.
Though the Mariner and Viking missions also
discovered the stuff in the 1960s and 70s,
this time it was detected from EARTH by an
awesome flying telescope.
The SOFIA telescope is a partnership between
NASA and the German Aerospace Center; it’s
basically a converted Boeing 747-SP with a
2.5 meter diameter infrared telescope poking
out the back.
Yes, a telescope, about the same diameter
as the Hubble Space Telescope, flying on a
jumbo jet high above most of the Earth’s
atmosphere.
So.
Cool.
But, what is atomic oxygen and why does it
matter that it's on Mars?
Well, oxygen is highly reactive, so it tends
to bond to other molecules.
When we breathe oxygen, we’re actually breathing
the most common form of oxygen “O-two”…
But when oxygen atoms exist by themselves,
chemists refer to it as “atomic oxygen.”
Atomic oxygen is formed when ultraviolet radiation
from the sun hits water molecules on Mars’
surface.
The energy of this impact spits out the oxygen
atom from the H2O molecule and sends the hydrogen
component high into the atmosphere which is
eventually lost to space.
It can also be produced from interactions
with carbon dioxide molecules in the atmosphere.
These free oxygen atoms quickly grab onto
lots of other different chemicals, like carbon,
chlorine, nitrogen and even other oxygen atoms,
creating breathable O2 molecules.
Atomic oxygen is rare at sea level on Earth,
because it will quickly bond with pretty much
anything.
But, if we look at Low Earth Orbit, at around
400 kilometers high… atomic oxygen makes
up 96 percent of the atmosphere.
Though very thin at these altitudes, the atomic
oxygen gas is so reactive that during the
first shuttle flights, it was eroding and
damaging the orbiters’ hull coatings, forcing
NASA to use a different formula that was less
reactive.
Anyway, detecting atomic oxygen on Mars can
tell us a lot about its atmosphere, its history
and, possibly, provide clues as to whether
or not Mars can sustain microbial life on
its surface, or if it ever did.
Also, you know why Mars’ surface is so rusty?
The red color is created by a coating of iron
oxide -- nope, even iron isn’t safe from
the atomic oxygen’s passion to bond.
SOFIA is now giving us a global view of the
whole of Mars, and by taking many 8-hour flights
to stare at the planet, we’re able to understand
how atmospheric atomic oxygen changes with
time.
In addition, SOFIA has detected ozone in the
high Martian atmosphere -- which is a molecule
of THREE oxygen atoms and a gas that is really
good at blocking ultraviolet light that can
damage life.
For any possible Mars microbes, the more ozone,
the better.
Ozone was actually detected on Mars in the
70s, and more recently by the European Mars
Express mission.
In a paper published by Nature Geoscience
researchers found that an ozone layer occasionally
forms over the southern pole.
Atmospheric currents and complex chemical
interactions are at play on Mars that don’t
occur on Earth.
These findings are not only useful for understanding
the diversity of atmospheric chemistry on
planets in our solar system, it provides a
wonderful insight to the possible interactions
on very alien worlds orbiting other stars.
And that’s not all.
Mars used to be a lot warmer and wetter than
it is now, conditions that scientists think
were habitable for microbial life.
So by understanding how the different types
of oxygen evolve over time, we can gain an
insight as to how much breathable oxygen (O2)
and how much ozone (O3) was around in Mars’
past, and, possibly help us understand if
life as we know it could still be hiding under
the red planet’s rusty rocks.
So, could aliens be living on Mars?
Check out this video from our friends over
at Alltime Conspiracies to find out more!
Would you like to see a DNews episode about
the awesome SOFIA telescope?
Tell us in the comments section down below!
And don’t forget click subscribe for new
episodes every day.
I’ll see you next time on DNews.